[Music]
your kid University rolls around you
then one day you realize that's not true
you do the story of a bunch of kids that
wake up to something terrible happening
[Music]
[Music]
Berry is in a town that is quite
unsettling the history project
don't murders missing kids there's not
like people to hire disappeared six
times the national average everyone
knows that there's something wrong about
this whole situation
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town because of one thing it comes
back every 27 years and more kids
disappeared
I saw something the clown yeah I saw him
too it turns out that all the murders in
Derry all of the missing children are
all connected look
it's all connected by the sewers as far
it lives
[Applause]
[Music]
the entity that is Pennywise focuses on
whatever that particular child fears the
most it is anything that you are ever
afraid of
it's definitely overcoming that fear and
we do it because work with each other
hang out with us places a loser - I can
take that that really bonds together
because we really have nowhere else to
turn there's no one else who really
cares for us we all know nobody else is
going to do anything these kids find the
strength and being together can't
pretend is gonna go away
[Music]
it's very emotional and it's terrifying
I had hoaxes but I was not prepared for
how good it really was
I'm sure my fans will really enjoy the
movie
[Music]
you
[Music]
you